[Applause]
hold up who's that
Jim what the hell
sup guys yo gone what are you what are
you doing
how's crime in that house the rhymes in
that I don't even Terry what are you
doing what are you doing with a cop car
I bought the car cop car Mart I got the
bat car Mart a uniform a uniform
Junction huh
and then I got a gun from everybody bang
gun tonight the gun story Thomas okay
we're good
there's no boats in it okay okay stop
again I thought there were no bullet all
right are you all right
we don't paw reform our friends he's
been doing coke back here did you see
this I've been thinking a cake for you
guys as a surprise Olli sober that's
great
sucks good for you I mean I love it yeah
we've got a report of several reports
actually that people have been finding
pubic hairs in their burritos yeah you
know anything about that no that's awful
yeah it is that seems well peculiar that
you handle food I don't touch the food
so how do you don't touch the food I
don't it's on the tray
I think it did I go to you guys they
take it
and toka pubic hair in it I say that
specifically well that's too bad about
the hair I mean I'm serious I'm gonna
I'm gonna call the police
somebody already did yeah here we are
Sheriff's Department what can we do for
you sir someone's pretty pubic hair in
the taco so can we get a couple of free
tacos or see what I can do Pedro's a
little peeved at me would you deal I put
some pubic hair in one eye
what do you consider your job skills to
be skating yep
high fiving skating in that father five
low five low five the antithesis of high
five and and singing singing so Terry
what you're basically saying is you
could be in Starlight Express if they
ever ever are bold enough to mount it
again yes yes possible Starlight Express
understudy you're off drugs now you're
totally clean I'm so clean it's not even
ridiculous not even ridiculous and
ridiculous here's the thing I find that
eerily a little bit disappointing
because if you're not on drugs if this
is you totally totally clean and you've
missed 19 parole hearings and you're
working on who let the clogs out that's
kind of disappointing don't you think
first of all it's one of the smartest in
my family reunion like hands down by the
rest of your family put up two fingers
for the same thing you can't say your
smartest at your family reunion hands
back hands down that's one thing that's
one thing I was but smarter than my
family yeah that's one and down no
that's yours that's part of this you're
saying two parts of the sentence part
one of the sentence end of the sentence
those aren't two things
you